It’s hard to take a picture of a moving target
—just ask any parent.
Scientists have the same problem with plant roots
under the microscope.
But now, one team has come up
with a unique technique
that lets microscopes automatically track
moving objects,
which they used to follow the growing roots
of these tiny plants.
By using lasers and glowing proteins
to piece together images in three dimensions,
they even created 3D videos of how the cells
in root tips grow and split over the course of days.
The team created a special lighting system
to keep the plants healthy,
and turned their microscope on its side
so the plants could grow upright.
A rotating plate allowed them to study
how gravity changes root growth,
which could one day help scientists understand
the best ways to grow plants in space.
But the invention isn’t restricted to roots.
The team also used this technique
with a different microscope
to watch how cells move around
in zebrafish embryos.
And since they released their program for free,
other scientists can use it to capture
stunning new perspectives
of just about anything that moves.